no I'm just I think this being an only
fans Creator and trying to do
anti-bullying is like a [ __ ] Paradox
to me
[Music]
show them show them the camera show the
camera they're pink
connoisseur for Halloween oh a Pink
Dinosaur yeah
that's cute Anthony was Peter Pan
it's keeping me out of this right Peter
pantheny thank you all right so uh we
were just talking about only fans
Peter fans all right anyways
um and there's an only fans model she
stabbed her boyfriend again again
there's like we did like three articles
like that in the past like year next
over it Nick's Oliver only fans models
stabbing their boyfriends well I just I
want to try to guess and I'm usually
wrong anyway so we'll guess go ahead
guess okay give it what was it again
give us a time only fans model uh-huh
that's all that's got fired from a
nursing job no yeah she shot up to the
top point four percent of all the
subscriptions wow in a very very quick
quick moment she's a new creator of well
newly shot to the top top spot so she
makes millions a month she makes a lot
so maybe she was doing like nudes only
and then she went full-blown hardcore
hardcore pornography and now she became
religious and quit she's got to be doing
something more unique It's gotta be
something pretty it's more unique pretty
weird really give me a hint give me a
hand this okay well there's only really
one way to explain she's stabbing your
boyfriend on only fanscon no that would
probably be crazy
she does videos sneezing with her eyes
open also crazy does she show pictures
of her cooch but each time it's face
painted something else wow wow who are
you subscribed to my brain wow
um so this only fans model uh gives her
fans control of her life
that's why she's so high so she puts
poles up and they also suggest different
things that she can do and things that
are voted on that like win or whatever
so she could be their Sim exactly so she
obviously nudes are already in play so
if they're like people are requesting
photos or doing this that happens but
other things like uh dumping her
boyfriend who was treating her wrong she
did that uh quitting her internship that
she was complaining about she did that
so like literally like real life things
that have real life I their consequences
and or benefits to it so barely sexual
sounds healthy sexual is also a part of
it I believe but she sounds almost like
a vlogger but you get to control where
the vlogger is going but the non-sexual
stuff sounds way more interesting it
does sound because now you got a
personal connection yeah she has
obviously be you know like kind of like
a genie has specific rules obviously she
can't do anything that puts herself or
other people In Harm's Way blah blah
blah blah blah
um but ultimately like you know people
are actually [ __ ] getting a lot of
that unique like like desire to just be
a part of something so she just
skyrocketed all of her fans she makes a
[ __ ] ton of money is there numbers on
how much she makes it doesn't show the
numbers it just shows that she literally
jumped up to the top point four percent
of like can you pay her to donate it all
maybe
um that's a good one you have a picture
of her I do have a photo of her
yeah she's definitely not ugly I'll say
that it's good because they could make
the content for her so she just makes
choices
she looks like American Apparel model
Kristen what are you trying to say right
now huh she's working toward her only
fans choose your own dance destination
what should I do today Bhangra or robot
or should I go to Millennium
[Laughter]
so yeah so she one of the crazy things
she actually uh was forced to dump her
now X
um this model known as Lori doubles as a
student and tennis player outside of her
online front and wanted to put her own
spin on her only fans content plays
tennis in college for a school like a D1
school and it doesn't specifically say
or she just does it recreationally she
probably doesn't Recreation don't call
yourself a tennis player
not around Asians yeah yeah if you're
not a pro you're just you just like
doing it yeah hobby yeah it's just a
hobbyist which is like most people
because they suck yeah here this this is
the uh professional
I just don't get on them this is the
professional branding yeah you know I
like watching tennis players like this
me too I love how the balls oh she's
professional dude if you're getting paid
to do that sport you're a professional
that's the definition
yeah but you're being paid for tennis in
a way yeah she's sitting by it she has
tennis accessories you know what I mean
she's really good at tennis
[Laughter]
you know why a lot of people that are
good looking guys and girls they get
called dumb they're like oh they're so
hot but so dumb yeah because in general
most people are [ __ ] dumb right but
when you're good looking you attract
more attention
so then you have to do less if most
people in the world are [ __ ]
dumbasses right but then if they're hot
you just notice them more because if
they're like average or like not that
good like they're they're not on your
radar but it just whatever they are like
if they're if they're if they're dumb or
smart or like athletic it just adds more
when they're attractive because you
can't like you give them so much more
attention so then they're like oh yeah
man good looking they're good looking
people are so dumb like but they're hot
though at least they got that and it's
like you don't know you're probably dumb
ass [ __ ] just you're probably more
stupider than that guy but but then no
one knows because you're not good
looking well yeah because you're not
even up for judgment nobody cares yeah
nobody cared to think of it you don't
get the same attention that they do good
looking people they're like celebrities
on a small scale they're under a
microscope yeah so you're saying the
more you get called dumb the more hot
you might be
the more people just notice like and
then like they never asked to be judged
on their intelligence they're just
people existing and walking around but
they get so much attention that people
just notice if they're stupid it gets
magnified wow that's a good theory I
like that thank you very much you're
also very dumb Nick
take some water pillow pictures man
that's why
school when you're like oh you're dumb
it's flirting I mean you're hot oh yeah
because you're dumb and hot this is true
this is true
um a correction on a prior fact it's not
point four percent uh it's actually in
the top point seven percent of creators
and also she's using 25 of her profits
to advocate for anti-bullying in schools
good for her I like this girl
I don't know about that one that sounds
kind of funny to me that's the one that
sucks yeah what is that what is it your
pro bowling no I'm just I think this
being an only fans Creator and trying to
do anti-bullying is like a [ __ ]
Paradox to me
explain well I mean she's just
supporting her customers right because
most of those [ __ ] probably get
bullied oh [ __ ]
coming back
usually kids so why would an only kind
of person be an advocate for children
high school kids no okay that's still
underage I bet there's a good percentage
oh we got a lot of high schools for sure
I'm sure a lot of [ __ ] kids are
jacking off to her probably yeah dude
teens teen boys are definitely buying
why are we thinking of this because it's
true dude because I was just I was like
dude this is a really cool detail I
should add suddenly where I hear I'm
like oh I was jacking off the song
highly when I was [ __ ] I don't know
that's where your whacking career starts
dude
think about the axis of pornography that
high school kid has nowadays oh yeah and
like how does that well that [ __ ] you
up the sad thing is as a kid you can
just run into it unwanted yeah but like
back in the day we had to [ __ ] search
like Mad Men for that [ __ ] like [ __ ]
detectives but now it's like you follow
a [ __ ] page all about cars they do a
brand deal with some [ __ ] bikini
chick and next thing you know there's
ads on your screen yeah would you put if
you put yourself in the position of your
mind when you guys were teenage boys
we'd be would you be finding money and
buying only fans probably oh my friends
had a credit card fishing ring online
through emails because we were too
scared to use our parents credit card
and it was only because of porn
they did some criminal [ __ ] just so they
could get porn accounts yeah and share
it amongst the friends and I was like
looking back I'm like dude they had a
they had a [ __ ] identity theft and
credit card ring at 13 years old
stealing information through email 13.
just so they could get porn that's how
porn was like gold right not that she's
on the sun that's a sitcom right there
like young Joe in today's world man that
the opportunity is endless bro he'd
probably be a millionaire by now he
would be he'd be a pimp on them by 15
he'd be a millionaire dude I [ __ ] up I
was born in the wrong generation it was
either this one or [ __ ] feudal Japan
[Laughter]
wrong time
[Music]